It's terrifying.
Absolutely terrifying!
One of the most terrifying moments I've ever experienced.
I may have wet the bed...
Yeah I nearly sh!t my pants
*spooky string music*
I'm already, I'm already feeling things
Nooo!
Nope! Nope. not watching that.
Hey you! You're supposed to give me some pee pee. Where's that pee pee? We're talkin' about pee pee here.
I really thought that if I took, if I went pee in the toilet it would bit my dick off.
Next time you sit on my I'm gonna bite off your tushy!
-Creature of darkness come to me. -Who are you talking to?
Oh shit yeah, I remember that
*storm sounds* -Whoah!
This kid's not a good actor. I can now see that.
*Screams*
Noooo!
Her voice. It's just so haunting.
That's like a horrifying story about a terrible car accident. Is that kid appropriate? Maybe not?
Oh my god!
Kevin's hair looks great. That's exactly how my hair looked like as a kid.
Okay so this is scary. It's only my imagination. Raaahhh! *Rawring*
-Here boy! -I hate this. I hate this.
-What's happening? -You're blowing up like a balloon.
-No that's disgusting. oh, uh -somebody do something, call the doctor.
Oh, ohh! -Stick her with a pin! -She'll pop!
-She has to be squeezed immediately before she explodes. -Explodes!
This is real life. This could happen to me, clearly.
It was still kind of like, creepy. It was really dark.
If I had children I would probably show this to them just to see what the effect would be on them.
I would show it to my own children.
This is a moment that will scare them purely for the joy of being scared and we just don't have that anymore.
I don't think it's doing anyone any favors to like scrub the grime off of movies because life has some grime on it. There's just not movies like that anymore.
*Creepy string music*
*Popping*